we have a voicemail number which you can
call anytime that number is
2192 David P here is a caller who is
called in after he figured out I am not
a Christian and he has some Choice words
for me I will tell you that
hey David yeah when I I'm just watching
your mouth on this TV here and you
saying that them prose testers
the proofs testers yes we're outside of
the Donald pump building when they were
outside of the courthouse that you you
don't even
well there were different videos and
some they were in one place and some
they were in the other
yeah well you know what I've done
figured out because you admitted
yourself you're not a Christian that's
true and you know what that makes me so
happy to hear
because
there is a God there is a Jesus there is
a Holy Spirit and Satan is going to be
coming here Satan we'll sing pray
tending to be Jesus and little waste of
sperms like you are going to follow I
hope so I want you to follow that piece
of all the way to the Lake of Fire
right along with Donald Funk okay well
very very powerful declaration and uh be
aware Satan will come back pretending to
be Jesus very very soon certainly
something to be scared of on the bonus
show today we are going to talk about
the truth of Manhattan district attorney
Alvin Bragg's alleged ties to
billionaire George Soros what are the
ties do they exist are they what
Republicans claim them to be we will
explore secondly Disney World after
everything that happened in Florida with
Rhonda Santos they don't say gay Bill
taking away Disney's uh rights there in
that neighborhood District that they
have after all of it is said and done
Disney is hosting a major Summit on gay
rights they seem really intimidated by
DeSantis guys we'll talk about that and
lastly the FED again raised interest
rates yesterday This Time by 25 basis
points despite the stress hitting the
banking system but in a context where we
are being led to believe that the fed's
work is seemingly close to done in this
cycle of interest rate increases where
are we what do we expect what is the
impact of raising versus lowering the
federal funds rate we're going to go
over all of it my friends on today's
bonus show sign up for membership at
joinpakman.com you will get instant
access to the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad Alex Jones despises
the bonus show but actual members love
it you can sign up at joinpakman.com you
can use the coupon code indict to say
save yourself significantly off of the
cost of membership we will see you then
and then we'll be back tomorrow with the
Friday show